California is currently experiencing one of
the most severe droughts on record, and new
NASA data says it’s worse than we thought.
Hey guys, Amy here for DNews.
A drought is a natural hazard that develops
slowly over time as a climate or environment
changes.
Water levels drop in the lakes and rivers
that we draw water from, forcing reliance
on underground stores called aquifers, sources
of fresh water that farmers also rely heavily
on, particularly in times of drought.
So what exactly is an aquifer?
An aquifer is a saturated rock that water
can easily move through.
Typically these rocks are permeable and porous,
though non-porous rocks like granite can be
aquifers if they’re fractured enough to
hold water in the free spaces.
This is where well water comes from; wells
are drilled into aquifers so the water inside
the rock can be pumped out.
If the well goes dry, you just have to dig
deeper and lower the water table.
Water flows into and eventually drains from
an aquifer in a cycle, so each has a natural
recharge and discharge zone or zones.
The recharge zones typically lie at higher
altitudes so water can flow down, but they
can occur wherever it’s natural for water
to move.
The discharge zones typically occur in springs
and low altitude wetlands.
The other benefit of this groundwater is that
the rock acts as a natural filter that traps
sediment and other nasty particles like bacteria
so the water that flows from the spring is
beautifully clean and clear.
But aquifers can become contaminated, typically
by humans.
Contaminants can flow into an aquifer from
a natural or manmade pathway that drains into
the waterlogged rock.
And as NASA’s GRACE mission is showing,
these underground water stores are drying
up.
The GRACE mission uses two satellites flying
in tandem to very accurately measure variations
in the Earth’s gravity field.
Changes to ocean currents do affect gravity
measurements.
So do movements of glaciers.
And so does the movement of ground water,
so these satellites can see that aquifers
are actually drying up because the gravity
in these areas is changing.
And it’s a global thing.
Using GRACE data of 37 aquifers over the course
of 10 years, scientists see that groundwater
is being rapidly depleted in the Middle East,
North Africa and Central Asia, and in the
United States.
The aquifer under California's Central Valley
is being badly overused.
Even aquifers in sparsely populated and wet
areas like the Amazon Basin and the Great
Plains are doing a little better thanks to
rainfall that replenishes the water stores.
That less water is available globally is starting
to affect political relations.
Border issues in some parts of the world are
becoming increasingly complex as fights break
out about access to water under those borders.
To learn more about how low water levels in
aquifers is affecting inter country relations,
check out this video from Test Tube News:
And there’s a link in the description below!
So wherever you are, it’s time to start
saving water!
Turn the tap off while you brush your teeth!
Don’t linger in the shower because you’re
bored!
What little things do you guys do to save
a few ounces a day?
Let us know in the comments below or on Twitter
@DNews.
And of course, for more DNews every single
day of the week, don’t forget to subscribe!